I want to talk a little bit about Flint
Michigan you may have forgotten about
this story many have because it's mostly
disappeared from corporate media
particularly in the wake of Donald
Trump's election but remember that whole
insane water fiasco in Flint Michigan
where the Republican governor was
involved in a major cover-up of the fact
that the water was completely tainted by
lead not much has been said about it
recently but NPR did do a really good
story about this reminding us that the
water is still not safe to drink out of
the tap without being treated and I'll
remind you that we were dealing with a
state of emergency in Flint Michigan
which was declared a year ago by the
mayor for it up Flint's drinking water
issues date all the way back up to 2014
when the city decided to change their
source for water to the Flint River tons
of donations went in tons of outrage
tons of water donations as well as money
fewer donations now not much attention
but still tainted water and the Flint
mayor Karen Weaver is frustrated saying
quote we're in year three actually of
not being able to drink water and that
still makes no sense to me and it
shouldn't make sense to anybody else and
indeed if you look at the tests of the
water in Flint the lead levels are
declining but you still need to be
filtering water for it to be safe to
drink the state says that more than 600
pipes have been replaced but that 30,000
suspect pipes remain I don't know what's
going to happen last week Congress
approved a hundred and seventy million
dollar bill in aid but the city says
that they're going to need tens of
millions more than that to actually
replace the lead pipes the state has
spent more than 200 million in
distributing three million cases of
bottled water and a hundred and forty
five thousand water filters the obvious
question so with filtration the water is
safe to drink it appears that it is Pat
but remember you're not filtering shower
water because those filters don't fit on
uh that don't necessarily fit fit in
your shower and in addition to that uh
it turns out that the filters themselves
are cesspools of bacteria which present
a whole new slate of problems for the
water
this is really bad and people aren't
really talking about it yeah and potable
water I mean that's one of the most
fundamental human rights that we have
regardless vivid cost the state or the
federal government money that's well
worth it and remember this was all
related to a financial decision that the
Michigan mayor I'm sorry governor was
involved in this is an absolute and
utter embarrassment and as usual yeah
we've started to see some prosecutions
but it's all very slow corporate media
has lost interest meanwhile we are as
the mayor of Flint Michigan said Karen
Weaver we are in year three of this in
Flint Michigan this is a United States
not that we have any more or less uh
sort of right to clean drinkable water
than anybody else in the world but we're
talking about the United States which
many people would not assume is a place
where you have to worry about the water
coming out of your pipes yeah this is
really just an indictment on the media
cycle they had this idea that the story
has been told so therefore it's over
with ice is still going on you're free
now countless people still affected send
me your thoughts about this i'm on
twitter at the pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show we will
take a break what a show we have for you
today